foreign
the Gentile World of Golf is in a state
of open Warfare this year live golf
moved to shake up the sport by taking on
the gulf establishment backed by two
billion dollars from Saudi Arabia's
Sovereign wealth fund live launched a
series of new tournaments to compete
with the PGA Tour and its European
cousin
Liv's chief executive former world
champion Greg Norman known as the shark
said golf was too stuck in its ways and
needed a revolution
fewer holes a condensed schedule and new
team events would help win the battle
for eyeballs all that Saudi money has
been put to work luring some of the
biggest names in golf such as Phil
Mickelson Dustin Johnson and Bryson
dechambeau with packages that reportedly
run into the hundreds of millions of
dollars
the PGA Tour responded by kicking them
out of its competitions
Liv's hostile takeover of golf part of
Saudi Arabia's wider soft power push has
not been smooth media coverage has been
dominated by questions about human
rights and oil money two of Liv's eight
contests took place at courses owned by
former U.S president Donald Trump it has
yet to sign up sponsors or broadcasters
and the golf establishment is fighting
back the PGA Tour has upped its prize
money while Tiger Woods and Rory McIlroy
are launching a new event where star
players compete on a golf simulator
designed to blunt interest in live and
attract a younger audience to a sport
with an aging fan base the next phase of
the fight is taking place inside the
justice system live and some of its
players sued to overturn the PGA ban
while the tour itself is now subject to
an Anti-Trust probe by U.S authorities
the Old Guard and the new Challenger
will keep taking swings at each other
both on the green and in the courtroom
[Music]